it's fun last night with the pics being
made with LeBron the Greek freak but I
like what Charlie had to say because
LeBron you know who knows what his
mindset is you know he's being coy and
Yanis made a few picks there and then
here's Charles Barkley last night Yanis
to trade everybody on his bench for
Anthony Davis good stuff and Charles
Barkley joins us this morning how much
fun did you have last night I had a
great time the dress was like eight
o'clock in the morning I can't believe
people up that early in the morning
they're super but it was firing in the
Indiana's did you expect anything you
know to happen and after a while with
and I know you guys discussed this like
you know the Lakers made it public sort
of embarrassed the pelicans and then it
felt like they were desperate and then
nothing happens with Anthony Davis how
surprised were you embarrass themselves
I think the humility is involved and I
think it's going to be interesting how
they repair those relationships you know
then you can't you know look at all the
guys in your studio you guys working
behind off they worked behind off all
the time if you said hey guys and it
goes on for week two three weeks
okay I didn't reach out to the photos
ship or TMT come back and work your
relationship is not gonna be the same I
mean we're dealing with human beings and
I thought that Lakers and bears all this
junk here and it was really unfortunate
who do you think is running the show is
LeBron and his agency or is Magic in
control and Rob pálinka totally I mean I
mean respect the bra of those who's not
magic but
you know when LeBron LeBron agent works
I said it three months ago whenever he
son Isaac got a text I said oh he's
going to the Laker and was really funny
about it I got a text from his phone I
liked about that respect I was on the
ESPN I said oh the fix is in he's going
to the Lakers
this before all this stuff really
happened how to do it he says yo the fix
was in I wasn't rich you know I got
respected yeah but the fences in he's
going to their Lakers and then it go to
three other teams those other three
teams don't have anything that after
Davis lost it made it look good for
things competing my illnesses I wanna go
to the Lakers and I think they got some
hard feedback then they put out there
three teams don't have anything
three for them so listen it's
unfortunate in my opinion but he's going
to the Lakers it's tough what would you
have made that deal if your New Orleans
to take those players from the Lakers
and those draft picks because if I can't
get out of the Davis aside a long-term
extension I'm not going to make the
three and the problem with the Boston
Celtics
they don't even though of Tyria our
state so they can't imagine if they
three Zealand Brown and Tatum and
anybody's ever doing the deal in Cairo
releases baby back it at the bottom of
the pile which is one great player and a
bunch of role players so I probably
would have made a deal if I was New
Orleans but you got a bunch of good
young players they're cheap right now
but say it's only it's only Twila
those are the two teams I think I'll
adjust again Apple but I'm also trying
to look at this now and what can happen
after this because if Anthony Davis is a
wonderful talent but he hasn't won
anything and
yeah I said before I said before the
season he's the second best player in
the world in my opinion but you know the
teams are stacked against him now you
think he's better than Durant I think
he's in the conversation I think here's
a tale you know what you are these right
there would take me as far as being the
best second best player in the world
right after LeBron and Oh II remember
saying that
don't forget jaundice so you know you
might have passed
your honour's might have passed
everybody to be honest with you you know
if I had an MVP bowed out with hopefully
honest a change of plan brief but John
is just what he's doing but let me tell
you something I think is a debate now
Yanis might be the best player in the
world the Kevin Durant situation is
always fascinating i yeah i mean just
the media and his relationship and
what's going on with Golden State and is
he is he helping matters or making it
worse with you know hit this approach
making it worse fascinating if he goes
to New York
I don't think Katie can make it in New
York like he's a great great player but
then you know how New York is he's only
been in Oklahoma City and San Francisco
that's like going to you know it's like
a little tough money you know but I
think it would be fascinating for a guy
like him really really going to New York
if they don't play in New York I tell me
when you go to New York they talk about
your family and they mean it
they might say bad things about you and
Oklahoma City's I'm Cisco Houston Dallas
but in New York Gillian Foster when they
talk about your family they really penis
by the way ran into Darius Rucker last
night and he told us about
going to Vegas with you for the De La
Hoya fight in the 90s and you'd rented
the penthouse suite oh I always have I
always have a good sweeping out a good
suite last weekend I went I go I've been
21 under 201 three years for the Super
Bowl I have a room wait
did you what happened with your Super
Bowl event this year well how many years
in a row no I won last year no but I
thought I actually thought the Rams was
gonna weigh in the gold I was wrong
I bet against a great hey listen let me
tell you something too Bill Belichick
he's already the greatest coach ever but
i'ma tell you something
ten lady Mike and I'm devastated before
he even tears Michael to it as the
greatest athlete of all time my opinion
he builded Marin Street through the
narrow Super Bowls and accomplices right
below Michael but after in tonight's
Super Bowl winners fix and lose a dream
on top of that included performances
ever I think Tom Brady to me might be
the greatest athlete of all time yeah
we've had that discussion here recently
because you know we love to put things
in context of where do where does he
stand you know but Mike did take off two
years to play baseball Charles so he
probably would have had but it's a lot
harder to win in the NBA that it is when
you and a one-and-done scenario
I mean think of that that's why I'm
gonna give Tom there is I mean lose one
game Micah has a lecturer losing to one
of two three games but to be in a
warrant on scenario and get to nine
world champ is just win six I mean like
I say I never even thought about anybody
compares Michael but I got a poem Brady
in my opinion my to pass Michael here's
the problem but people have a problem
with this Charles when they go all
greatest athlete but he's not a great
athlete he's he's got the best resume
because they will say well what kind of
athlete is Tom Brady so we get caught up
in how athletic you are and he's not
Michael Vick but you know I yeah but I
think when we say the greatest football
player of all time somebody wants to say
Lawrence Taylor Jerry Rice or Jim Brown
because they have athletic achievement
and I know I mean I don't think they won
two Super Bowls maybe three but to get
to nine Super Bowls but they're one and
done that that's what the caveat is to
me he has to being a one-and-done
scenario like in the NBA you know
Michael Kobe LeBron guys like that they
have a decided advantage in a seven-game
series they can dominate four games or
they can lose two or three games in
particular I'm super bowls or instant
one and down scenario I mean it's
incredible yeah and like I say Bill's
already the greatest coach out there
with you know big saving Pat Summitt
Phil Jackson Popovich of those guys
I mean but forgot to get to nine Super
Bowls in a 1 in terms of Aereo
is crazy were the AT&T Pebble Beach
pro-am have you played in this event
[Laughter]
hey it's great to talk to you on short
notice and safe travels there and
hopefully we'll we'll see you soon
all right man I'm in Philadelphia we're
retired Moses falafels landed
we're retirement motors of along Jersey
the greatest influence in my life over
to my grandmother can't wait to be there
tonight that's awesome
Thank You Charles such the great Charles
Barkley joining us for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]